Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody.
You know, we are really starting to do it,
we are really seeing in the United States
and increasingly around the world that we
are pointed to an exit from this global pandemic.
For many people, it already feels like it
is over.
Statistically, medically, it is getting closer
and closer to being over.
And we knew, we suspected we said it was written
in the fall that the societal and cultural
end to the pandemic would likely come before
what we would call the medical end, which
is we are back to sort of baseline risk of
death from being in the world globally.
We are not there yet and many countries are
very far from that.
But let's start with what we can say that
is going well and then we'll talk about the
things that are still the question marks.
Coronavirus cases in the United States are
now down 95 percent from a peak of two hundred
and fifty five thousand new cases per day
in January, down to about 13000 cases per
day.
Unfortunately, we are seeing some spikes among
unvaccinated people.
I'm going to talk about that momentarily.
Shocker, right?
The people who are not vaccinated are still
getting the virus.
More on that in a bit.
But a 95 percent decline overall is a great
start.
Now, what about deaths with deaths?
We are seeing the numbers come down relatively
quickly.
Once again, deaths peaked in late January,
around 3500 a day and are now down to about
350 a day.
That is a decline of about 90 percent in terms
of daily covid deaths for comparison, because,
again, we may now feel that it's not safe
until we are at zero risk.
We're never going to be at zero risk.
Life doesn't have zero risk.
The question is, when are we back to baseline
risk?
In a normal flu season in the United States,
just on average, about one hundred and ten
people die per day.
Now, sometimes we have a really bad flu season
and 250 people die a day.
But in an average flu season, there's one
hundred and ten flu deaths per day.
We're now at 350 covid deaths per day.
So we're not down to what we might call baseline
background risk, but we're getting closer
and closer to that.
If we look around the world, the numbers are
also looking better and better.
Global cases are down 55 percent from their
peak.
At one point, we were seeing 830000 new covid
cases per day.
We're down more than half to about three hundred
and seventy five thousand cases per day.
It's still a long way to go, but more than
half reduced.
And then global deaths are down about 40 percent.
Global daily deaths peaked at more than 14000
in January, almost peak there again in early
April, now down to about nine thousand deaths
a day from covid globally.
Still a giant number, but declining more and
more.
Now, in a moment, we're going to talk about
the growth in cases among unvaccinated people.
But before we get to that, the new issue floating
around is that of the Delta variant, which
is floating around.
Tomorrow, we're going to be joined by Dr.
Ashish Jha from Brown University.
And we will talk to him about the Delta variant,
as well as a number of other issues.
But what is the deal with the Delta variant?
So the Delta variant is indeed more transmissible.
More and more cases in many countries are
coming from the Delta variant.
So even if in the aggregate cases are going
down, more and more of the cases we are seeing
are the Delta variant.
If you are fully vaccinated, you really don't
have much to worry about, especially if you're
in a highly vaccinated area.
Bob Wachner, who's the chair of the UCSF Department
of Medicine, had a good Twitter threat about
this, where he wrote, quote, I know everybody's
sick of playing three dimensional covid chess,
sorry, but the Delta variant forces us back
to the chessboard.
Ergo, this thread, if you're fully vexed,
I wouldn't be too worried, especially if you're
in a highly bakst region.
If you're not vaccinated, I'd be afraid, maybe
even very afraid.
Why?
Let's start with the things we know about
the current situation.
Then layer in new information about the Delta
a.k.a. Indian variant.
Then we'll end with what I'd suggest you and
we do.
The current U.S. situation is good cases.
Hospitalization deaths are falling fast, largely
due to our fabulous vaccines in San Francisco,
where he works with 70 percent of those over
age 12 fully vaccinated.
We're nearly in a post covid world.
This is a doctor saying this.
Everybody's opening up, including on Tuesday,
today, California.
That's fine for now.
Sadly, half of the U.S. aged over twelve remains
unvaccinated.
And in certain states, mostly southern and
right leaning, it's more like two thirds that
are unvaccinated.
We know that a small number of that.
Sedated people will get breakthrough infections,
but they'll rarely get very sick and will
almost never die of covid.
So still, you know, we have to balance the
people who never wanted to take any precaution.
And there were many of them.
And for a long time, the former president
was one of them with the doom and gloom ers
who are still saying don't go out, open nothing,
work from home only no kids in schools, masks
everywhere.
Everything is dangerous.
We can never, ever, ever take our masks off.
We've got to balance that.
And the balance, that balancing act is the
vaccines work really well against all the
variants, including the Delta variant.
If you're fully vaccinated, meaning the requisite
number of days beyond your last dose, whether
it's two doses or one.
And we bolster that safety by being around
people who are vaccinated.
There are now states in the 70 80 percent
vaccinated range for those who are eligible,
your risk there of any variant is going to
be dramatically lower than if you are in a
place where only 35 or 40 percent of the population
is vaccinated.
It is merely math.
And so all of this is mostly common sense.
Tomorrow we will speak to Dr. Ashish Jha more
specifically about the variants and how to
interpret vaccine efficacy numbers.
But it shouldn't shock us that although the
big picture is looking better and better,
cases are rising again among the unvaccinated.
Let's talk about
that next.